he's one of the best in the business
he's an all-pro tackle and he protects
the quarterback there in san francisco
and the 49ers have a big game against
the green bay packers don't they in the
divisional playoff weekend he is trent
williams here on the rich eisen show how
are you trent
i'm doing good rich appreciate you
having me on how you doing i am i'm
great man i just you know um i just love
watching you play trent
um and the number of people
that talk about how good you are did you
hear kittle say you're the best player
he's ever played with did you hear that
one
uh
i don't i don't i don't know if i heard
him say that um personally but
you know i mean that's
that that's an incredible you know thing
and very special with somebody like
kyoto you know i
really feel like he's the best titan
i've ever played with so you know the
film is mutual
so um i i know you're not uh you know a
doctor you don't play one on tv uh
there's just a general
uh conversation about your quarterback's
health how how does jimmy g look to you
uh getting ready for this big game
against green bay um
i mean
i thought i'd probably go for my
ignorance i i had no idea he was
he was injured he seemed pretty good to
me last time i laid out eyes on him i
don't know you know jimmy's a tough
cookie man
so you know i know this game means a lot
and i know that he'll do everything he
can to be there so what is your role do
you think on this team
trent i know what you play what position
you play but spiritually in leadership
and also
um through your play what do you view as
your role on the 49ers um you know
honestly rich i've been i've been around
for a long time and uh
you know a ton of these guys on the team
been watching me play since they were in
middle school or you know high school so
um you know i think my role is just
that that kind of that emotional god has
pretty been through i mean it's pretty
much been through everything in the nfl
you know from
a lot of ups and downs so um you know i
just
i feel like i can relate to every player
in their locker room at some level
whatever
whatever level they are or whatever um
phase they are in their career i feel
like i can relate to them and um you
know and that's just how i try to
motivate me about by relating to the
guys and just helping through everything
again also
i'm trying to lead by example and what i
put into the game every day what do you
put into the game every day walk with
somebody everything man i think uh
this game consumes me it controls my
mind that consumes everything
you know
98 of the day i think my mind is on
football um
just visualizing making plays for my
team
and uh just trying to continue to
transcend the position and love tackling
and to show people that you know we can
be more than just
somebody you know
playing in the phone booth and and
blocking one guys and play
trent williams here uh on the rich eisen
show and then just the general sense of
the physical nature that you guys bring
to the table what is it like um to watch
devo work
trent uh
devo is special b-boy
he's not like for any any club i've ever
seen um
you know when i first seen people i
think last year
when i was watching highlight from the
watching film from the previous year at
19 when i got there at 20.
and uh you know i told a man
that i feel like he was one of the best
people i've ever seen with the football
you know he reminded he reminded me a
lot of um
i've never seen a guy with that verse
other than percy harvard you know and i
used to and to me he was one of the
better guys i've ever seen in person and
then you know i think this year he just
blew it out the water there's really no
comparison to a player like bebo
and uh i think we are very very
blessed and lucky to have him on our
team and i think
you know
kyle's
kyle being such a genius and
as an offensive minded coach
um i think that that marries up
perfectly with one of the you know
unicorn weapons that we have in depot
trent williams here on the rich eisen
show you know the the story goes
certainly over the last couple days
trent is that after
you got the ball back um picking off dak
on
sunday debo told
kyle give me the ball
you gave him the ball you scored
that's the way it went is that the way
it went over the weekend yeah yeah
exactly how i went
you know but that that's devo man
he's a competitor like no other he loves
contact seems like he loves contact like
he just relishes he loves everything he
the thing about it is he can run he can
run past 99 of the players on that field
so
you know
that that's already scary enough and
when
you think you you want to go run and get
an angle on them
foot in the ground and and all you see
is this helmet strikes that's a scary
thing for for you know defensive back
linebackers
trent so you said earlier in this
conversation you think football all the
time you talk you know
your mind is on it 98 of the time which
defender in the league makes you think
about
the upcoming battle with against him
more than anybody else
in the
uh league know honestly honestly rich
we
we can't week out you know whoever i'm
i'm going against it that's probably you
know
i think about him just as much as i
think about anybody else um but
you know i think the guys who yeah i
mean that's you guys can keep me up at
night you know or the ones who um
pretty much can do it all like you know
chandler jones and uh
vaughn miller you know all the smith
back and you know when he was in this
run and um
you know guys like that you know i i'm
luckily enough i don't have to play
against nick but if i if i did he'll be
a guy that that can cause for sleepless
nights but you know blocking blocking
the defensive end is one of the hardest
positions on
one of the hardest tasks to do in the
nfl so they're some of the best
well-rounded athletes when you talk
about size
speed athletic ability and strength
where does the in terms of difficulty in
your job does it uh uh rank for you to
be in motion on a quarterback sneak and
get down before the quarterback snaps
the ball tren oh man i mean it's not the
task is not that difficult um
you know i think you know just with it
with a chance to
clench that that playoff you know win
and to advance
you know uh
you know jimmy just kind of rushed the
operation a little bit
you know to the the the um the idea is
to catch the guys off guard obviously
we're shifting me yes to the other side
of the line yes
you know another strong side
you know and and that and that in turn
you we want them to kind of relax maybe
shift the line a little bit you know
you can do a tackle over shift and
and uh while they're doing that you know
that's when we would like to catch him
off guard and sneak the ball but
you know uh jimmy seen him on the knee
so he
he went ahead and snapped the ball
which it was just just a tad bit
premature that was
you know it sucks man that's the game
isn't
i mean football is a game of inches and
you see how sensitive it is right there
yeah i mean without that though he
wouldn't have the ending of the game
that we're all talking about still as a
country and a football loving nation
where were you throughout that whole
process when dak went on that dash and
the clock sticking down trent
hey uh i had a front row seat
yeah um
yeah i i saw you took off i thought it
was an interesting call but
you know hey
obviously that's something they work on
i bet no i mean i think they need to
work on it a little bit better but you
know
were you surprised you were surprised by
the fact that he because obviously the
defense was given
you know more than just inside the
hashes you know it was inside the
numbers pretty much from numbers to
numbers even more so were you surprised
that he took off like that trent
i mean
obviously
it was it was designed quarterback run
so yeah praise just calling but you know
probably you running the play that he
was called that was called
um but yeah that to me that's a
surprising move with
i don't know how many seconds left maybe
what 14 18 seconds
yeah pretty much yeah so yeah so that's
that's a pretty that's a pretty
that's a pretty you know
a pretty dicey move in my opinion
especially if you had lamar jackson that
quarterback then you know that's a lot
of space for for a guy like that but
you know as far as like
i don't
i don't i didn't think that was uh the
best play call that they could have been
winning that in that period of time but
you know okay definitely appreciate it
for so as you and i are talking right
here trent williams you think jimmy
garoppolo is going to be playing in uh
green bay that's your sense oh i mean i
just said i don't know
his injury status uh personally but
um i know jimmy like i know jimmy if he
can go he would definitely be sitting at
the green bay okay do you think you guys
can win the super bowl you got that
sense what do you think
i mean i think any any team left in this
playoff run right now probably feel like
they could win the super bowl so yeah i
think you know i it would be hard to
to go out there and play in a 10 degree
weather or whatever it is
if i didn't think i had a chance to win
so yeah of course i think i probably
feel like every other player that's
doing this thing
yeah you got any tips on how to stay
warm
at all oh
no you know honestly
i mean we're gonna be surrounded by a
hundred thousand people so you know
that'll keep you warm you got heated
benches you know all big jackets and
stuff right so you know all right if i'm
getting cold that mean that we and we
are on the field a lot of you who's
possessing the ball so i'll take that
okay hey man
thanks for the time um congrats on your
career as it currently stands and the
run that you're on you go we'll chat
again soon appreciate it thank you you
guys one of the best in the business
trent williams of the san francisco
49ers here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here